breaking the rules right out the gate
here I have a group question for all of
you kind of a fun silly one let's say
you as in real you you caught the smile
curse you need someone to confide in who
is someone in your real life that you
would pick to tell that would actually
believe you oh my God that is easy easy
go
I mean scoot he's like he's like like my
like my boyfriend he's just like he's
he's dark he believes anything you know
what I mean I'd be like so let's me like
oh my God no way
right on mine my brother maybe two your
brother too everyone I have in my life
I only have one person that I feel like
I can actually confide in that moment
that's my five-year-old daughter she
will believe anything I say and no
matter how crazy it sounds but like
there's there's a reality to it because
she doesn't understand the way a lot of
things work so if I explain something to
her that I'm experiencing she's
instantly gonna believe it and she's
very helpful I feel like in that moment
I can't really present that to anyone
else and have don't tell your
five-year-old daughter about it I'd have
to but look I'm seeing this thing
Daddy's losing his mind and like I need
you to be the one to tell everyone
what's happening she'll be like I got it
yeah of course of course you're losing
your mind Dad I've seen smile two kids
have that you know what I mean exactly
they have none they have no judgment
yeah
yeah I'd probably tell my wife she I
think my wife would believe me
I could definitely less exciting I
believe you I'd be like I know you
[ __ ] was
I'll be like hell no I did I'd be like
come over don't see I have a life like
no please I got a couple people I think
I could tell my wife I got probably my
buddy Jake and Chris I can tell too and
they'd be like let's do something about
this I think I feel like I wanted to
test Jesse's Theory out on my
three-year-old niece later but now I
feel awful if I do that
yeah I got enough Maniacs in my life to
help me
important people to have all right uh so
see you've accomplished quite a bit
already but this is the debut lead
performance in a feature here so thank
you out of all of the past projects that
you've done is there any number one on
the call sheet on one of those where
they did something that you found
influencing your work on smile whether
it's through the performance or just as
being a leader on set oh that's such a
good question
um like I learned a lot I learned a lot
about like
how to I don't I didn't do everything
as well as
um some of the people that like I've
worked with you know what I mean and
that's okay like I think that they
probably had to learn that themselves
too like I was trying to emulate
you know those amazing number ones that
I've worked with that really like no
matter what was going on like had had
your back and all that stuff and
um
I think that I learned a lot I learned
and it's it's a it's a good like um
you know it was definitely trial by fire
this is a very intense one to also take
on like the leadership position that you
need to like hold
um so you know I'll do things
differently next time and also you know
take a lot of stuff with me that did
work so
all right I'm gonna build on that and
kind of throw it both of your ways uh
Kyle and Jesse so given the fact that I
think so is he's bound to be a number
one on the call sheet in many future
Productions but it's something that she
did on set as a leader and a scene
partner for the two of you that you're
excited for more actors out there to get
to experience in the future
I
think one of the most important things
you can do is yeah I mean you really set
the tone right so if you're coming to
set late if you're coming to set
unprepared if you're coming to set not
knowing your lines or whatever like it
kind of sets a tone on set that if
somebody doesn't care why do I care and
you know every single day so she showed
up she delivered she knew her line she
was ready to go not only did she know
her line she brought it every
take every day and that really
you know that that as an actor makes you
want to step up to the plate and and
rise to the occasion of your you know of
of what your co-star is putting down so
it's it's it's a really it's a really
good thing and and and it's it's a hard
place to be I mean you're captain of a
ship that's you know six seven hundred
people sometimes and it is it's a lot
and a film like this that is so so
intense it's like running a marathon to
be able to
hold that together and keep everything
moving as well Associated is really it's
especially for your first film I mean it
was incredibly impressive it was yeah
thank you I don't know and to Ed I mean
her her level of commitment scene by
scene take by take was
so impressive you know it's so
impressive to watch because eventually
you start to see fatigue set in or you
know you start to see a lot of things
that like we as actors cannot control
um but to be able to still stay
committed to the role and committed to
the scene committed to the story to this
character and to to be real time and
time again is very impressive it's also
extremely hard to do so like
Bravo thanks guys well-deserved
compliments right there speaking of how
incredibly challenging this role is
emotionally and also physically so see
how how do you actually nail the
performance but also make sure that
you're taking care of yourself in the
process yeah I think that the second one
was a bit um forgotten um but like I
also do think that like sometimes in
times of like great stress we also need
to just like
kind of survive and and like I I don't
know I feel like there's a lot of like
societal pressure put on like self-care
and self-care and we have to like make
sure that we're also getting like a
massage and a facial it's like it's not
realistic and like nobody's able to do
that in the real world so like I don't
really know why like it would be you
know what I'm saying like I think like
reality TV if I had to watch it all
night and like not sleep because I need
to distract myself I was like okay it's
just kind of like radically accepting
that you're trying to survive you know
what I mean I think everyone could use a
dose of that did you have anything to
detox after the shoot was over
a good way to treat yourself
I went back to LA like literally
immediately I was like get me on the
next flight I need to get out of New
York um it was just nice to like be just
I I like I feel like better here I don't
remember God what did I do I don't
remember probably like a lot of things
but whatever you put yourself through
it's well worth it because it reads
quite well on screen and it's very
effective and seriously this movie
doesn't work without an A plus
performance from you and you definitely
nail it they're gonna kick me out that
means Jesse it's time for the obligatory
the boys question
I'll go I'll go this route with it so
the official Twitter account I believe
shared an image of you sprayed with a
good deal of blood and I love me my
blood and gore effect so how does the
season four level of Carnage that a
train experiences compared to the
previous seasons is it more oh
um
I can't say that if it's more or less
what I what I can say is it's surprising
nice it's surprising it's surprising for
everyone
that's all I can say
honestly with that show my head is
swirling with a million possibilities
that I'm very much enjoying right now so
I appreciate the t's huge
congratulations on this one and now I'm
gonna go watch dinner in America on Hulu
10 times there we go always very much
always congratulations guys thank you
thank you